in the lobby of Ramsey solutions they're
here Nick and Kelly are with us hey guys
how are you Dave what's going on
welcome welcome good to have you where
you guys from Kansas City couldn't tell
by the jersey awesomeness and you're
here to do your debt-free screen yeah
very cool and how much have you guys
paid off 40,000 in 18 months
way to go love it love it and your
income during that time a stunt it went
from a stunning 28,000 to a little over
one hundred and twenty thousand dollars
whoa how do you do that in eighteen
months got into real estate and the nice
thing about real estate is the more
people you help the more money you make
there you go change yeah what do you do
Kelly um currently stay-at-home mom
before that I was a social worker okay
very cool love it
so what kind of debt was the 48 thousand
good Sallie Mae good old Sallie Mae we
gave the old woman or walking papers yep
hit the street lady no place here for
you that's right good for you guys so
what happened 18 months ago that changed
everything I graduated college and all
of a sudden I got all these bills saying
oh you owe us and it freaked me out and
I got tired of sending all my payments
to Sallie Mae and because we have a lot
of businesses and dreams and things we
want to give to and I just knew I didn't
want to be normal
I didn't wanna be broke and so it just
set me on fire got your book Total Money
Makeover and I said art we're doing this
thing let's jump in right away very cool
very cool so when did you all get
married Kelly we got married on May 10th
of 2014 okay so about the just this is
all started right after you got married
then yeah okay very cool very cool well
congratulations you two
thank you mean your income is going Zoom
Zoom you knockout Sallie Mae you're
working together young marriage
everything's working right this is good
very good story I love it so what's your
advice to people that are coming out of
school and they're kind of overwhelmed
and they're
like an old Sallie Mae and you're going
and she's gonna be with us a while
I hope our story can be an inspiration I
think the big thing I tell people is
anything that's really worth doing is a
lot of work upfront and man we're on the
other side of this and it's totally
worth it and listen the politicians I
say you need their help to do it or
anybody have broke people are making fun
of you just keep moving forward just
don't quit I mean we we work together I
wrote a goal and just went after an it
man it is totally worth it
Wow well congratulations you guys thank
you very very well done man absolutely
cool so $48,000 what was the hardest
part no no I drove what you call a
hoopty absolutely the car had a it was a
safety hazard I think people were
generally concerned about my life I mean
it was always a miracle getting point A
to point B I'd had about 300,000 miles o
in the air condition he did not work and
the windows did not go down this cars
nasty yeah I jokingly told people made
me get to work early so I can meet the
heat man yep well the yeah when you
drive a car that increases your prayer
life you know things are right on that
yeah Wow it's absolutely crazy well
congratulations you guys thank you very
very proud of you all right we have a
copy of Chris Hogan's retire inspired
book that's the next chapter become very
wealthy and outrageously generous yes
very cool stuff and your son's with you
yes yeah and how old is he he's 15
months 15 months and what's his name
Paul all right there he comes into the
picture for those of you looking into
your radio live on the YouTube stream
you can watch these beautiful families
as they do their debt free screams by
the way just go to the Dave Ramsey show
channel on YouTube but hey awesome stuff
all right Nick and Kelly and Paul
$48,000 paid off in 18 months making 28
to 120 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream you ready oh here we go
three two one
love it love it love it man that is
awesome that's exactly how you do that
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in the car